si un vaccin contre le govic 19 été
trouvé 26% des français refuseraient
d'être injecté ce chiffre confirme une
tendance bien ancrée dans notre pays la
défiance envers la vaccination dans les
années 50 trois vaccins sont
obligatoires pour les nouveau-nés contre
la poliomyélite la diphtérie et le
tétanos
à l'époque une partie des français se
posent des questions
j'ai entendu dire que ces vaccinations
était dangereuse
est ce exact on ne peut nier que
l'injection de vaccins le provoque
quelques réactions
la grande majorité des médecins
défendent la vaccination il met en avant
le progrès sanitaire qu'elle représente
pour nos sociétés comme la en 1962
d'accord parce qu'il est depuis 1954 la
ligue pour la liberté de vaccination
regroupe les plus sceptiques des
français de tous horizons sociaux en
voici en 1980 les gens sont conditionnés
dans le système vaccinale parce qu'il
manque d'informations la formation
des accidents ne circule pas beaucoup
plus d'accidents que des lacs sionistes
veulent bien y prétendre les accidents
de vaccination selon la ligue
il serait la cause de maladie ou de mort
subite chez les nouveau nés
même si le lien n'est pas clairement
établi avec la vaccination les parents
doutent notamment après une affaire en
1986 quatre morts subites qui seraient
dus aux vaccins tetra coke c'est en 2017
que les anti vaccins se sont le plus
exprimés juste avant la promulgation de
l'extension à 11 vaccin obligatoire pour
la petite enfance
cette loi était votée car des maladies
comme la rougeole ressurgissent la
vaccination était jusque-là recommandé
mais pas de quoi convaincre tous les
français les maladies il faut vivre avec
sa conscience peut pas être absolument
protéger à cent pour cent de toutes les
maladies on n'est pas immortel quelque
chose santé publique
encore aujourd'hui la vaccination à ses
pourfendeurs selon une étude mondiale de
2010 9 33% des français pensent que les
vaccins sont dangereux et 19 % estiment
qu'ils ne sont pas efficaces
[Musique]